what is up everybody Anna Mack here for
anime uproar welcome to another episode
of grant cafe in this episode we're
gonna be looking at the upcoming almost
here spring 2018 anime season and
looking at what it talking about what
exactly we are most looking forward to
watching and what you should potentially
watch and potentially what you should
avoid and I'm sure our boy animal
Ethan's gonna have plenty of ideas on
what we should avoid an American welcome
to the show to avoid hell nah I'm gonna
suggest some there are some very good
super shows coming out hey good to have
you my guy also we got Joe Joe talks too
much
hello hello everybody I do that thing
where I talk a lot about it and also not
what God is in the quick programming
notes for the next few weeks Red Cafe
will be an ox tacos channel because I
will be out of the country for a few
weeks with very limited access to
Internet
so Knox will handle rent cafe same time
but on Knox's channel keep that in mind
okay let's get right into it everyone in
the chat welcome let me know what you
guys are looking forward to I mean let's
just get let's just get it out of the
way and talk about my hero academia
season three first yeah everything else
can just fall from that because we all
know we all know where this is heading
yes I'm so excited
thoughts Jojo okay I am an anime only so
I have only been told
pure hype is on the way so I'm just so
excited this is like my eye I have no
words the one who talks has no words I
feel like I'm feeling the same things I
haven't read the manga at all so it's
like the anticipation is killing me
especially how like the manga readers
are like pumping it up exactly like
everyone's just like oh you thought oh
you thought the term in arc was hype oh
no no no no like everybody's just like
everybody's just blowing it
the water with like how cool it's gonna
be so I just I I need it now I need my
superheroes now you guys haven't read
the manga I have oh yeah wolfy Thomas
it's gonna be very interesting I know
what I'll talk we don donated $2 to say
tell me what to watch a you senpai
that's the point my friend we will tell
you what to watch and you must always
blindly follow what people tell you
don't forget that always probably why
here or Kadima guys when I read the next
two arcs in the manga is when I really
was like this is a sick series like
that's what really got me into we learn
more about the world we see some epic
fights we meet epic villains is gonna be
insane so that is why I definitely 100%
and what I say it unless they screw it
up majorly and just make it all filler
or something like somehow which I hope
not if they follow the same example they
did in the previous two seasons this
will definitely be the best season by
far that makes me so happy I know I'm
excited I'm pumped up he's making it
worse all the manga readers just keep
pumping it up but like after you guys
know because if the thing is I know from
the anime only people there like met
season two was great it was this is
something like season two was fine like
the stain stuff was really good but like
you like the next stuff is the real [ __ ]
like I love the villain arcs and the
next like long period of time in the
manga is straight-up villain stuff gonna
be like you know gunk is gonna be hype
I'm definitely I think this season could
be the one that really propels my hero
academia as the successor to like the
big Naruto's and Dragon Balls and things
like that I've been I've been expecting
that for a bit that that this would be
that MHA would it was gonna be like the
next big like the next big thing mmm I'm
just dying in general just for like how
everything was developed in the second
season and then just every episode is a
freaking cliffhanger so it easily just
gets you so in exactly like
well it leaves you going like why got to
be like that like at the end of every
episode it was literally like why you
gotta do me like that I gotta play me
like that like a sickle one kills for me
I was okay with the second season not
that it was it was okay
I mostly preferred the first one but um
from seeing new characters that are
gonna be introduced brand new villains I
think it's gonna be really good to see
what with them what it's gonna be about
yeah and you you learn more about like
the whole background of all night and
all that stuff so it's gonna be very
cool 100%
very cool I know no talk who said that I
missed his first snapchat where he said
that he's seen only 700 anime if you've
seen 700 anime that's pretty damn good
I gotta that's gotta say that's like
recon level of harem watching me you
probably did oh Jesus I don't think I've
watched 700 maybe 300 to 400 I don't
really keep track and record of my anime
list I just you know have them up in my
head
yeah like if you what I know I watch
almost all of the harem all of the whole
night if you watch 700 anime you've
probably seen a hell of a lot of caroms
like there isn't getting around it right
so I feel like you have to go through a
lot of those by the way shout out to not
so fired up Nick Baker fire caster FISA
on bunch of people I see me high low
miles Sammy a bunch of people that are
like I'm known for in here around here
for months or even years beat everybody
good to see you Tosca work take ha um
yes so my heart gave me a definitely
huge height
I am wondering we know it's gonna be 25
episodes so I am wondering how they're
gonna order it whether they're gonna
cover just and make stool arts in the
mom and kind of stretch it out or if
they're gonna cover the next three arcs
which there's like all three are really
good so I I am curious to see how they
do it like what I'm very excited I just
need more yeah I'm the same way them
just at that level where I'm like just
bring out more because I'm sick of the
cliffhangers I'm sick of manga people
building this up so like the biggest
peak and I just want to jump off that
cliff and watch it it's one of the great
of hype right now what it's like like
I'm the last time I was like like on the
edge of my seat like killing myself over
like what's the next that lay like why
you gotta leave it like that was like
maybe haikyuu
was like you gotyou I need the next
episode like it's very rare like who's
gonna win volleyball versus oh my god
the war is gonna end but I am very sure
another season of high Q because that's
when they're gonna be you know playing
in the real tournament there needs to be
another season point q thanks for sure
it's awesome like one of the best sports
series I've ever watched thank you
exactly and it's at least in parts of it
but my brother I think I've seen it all
and he loves it it's really really good
like I know it sounds silly lights like
on like who's gonna win the volleyball
game but they make it seem like like
world ending events when a game goes on
like it's really from like Sports anime
personally just yeah necessarily I
haven't really given them a chance but I
just feel like yeah I'm like do I really
care that much about who wins the game
you know I wanna why do that same yeah I
do that - I never given a chance and
that's my problem but I need to give a
couple of a chance I gave Yuri on ice a
chance I have Yuri ah nice figures
staring at me and the other side of the
corner it's not a show like so many
frapp down that show is god-awful as
everyone made it to be it doesn't work -
it got great but yeah it was a good show
it's not terrible but it's like like
shattering because of the fan base so
like that's exactly I said that a long
time ago that like the fan base will
actually it's our this series for so
many people even they sound like no
screw that like I can't like this
because of how the fan base has made it
yeah well it's it's that even like
crunchyroll shoving it up everybody's
ass where they're like look at how
awesome Yuri are nice is it's like I
know dude I'm watching it like you just
you just got blocked
you just got blocked on Twitter Oh
[ __ ] III AM block
by miles oh gosh oh I'm gonna get for
example I kept getting ads on my
Facebook and stuff before citrus or I
call it sytrus but it's like I don't
care man I'm not gonna watch URI incest
like I'm not gonna watch it like you can
advertise it to me as much as you want
I'm not gonna [ __ ] watch it that's the
thing like it got to the point where
people who were like they're like I'm
good on you're a nice man from like I'm
good - oh my god I hate it like and it's
it
you can't like push into people's face I
love URI on ice but I'm also aware that
it is not anime of like that year that
was mob psycho but like you know what I
like it that guy could go on about that
show forever I think there's like a
movie coming out or an OVA I thought it
was a second season they're supposed to
be yes that's gone I'll take either one
I'm already on the second season is
coming also in the chat I saw simply
roles original ink
it's your boy Scully a bunch of familiar
faces welcome alright so yes my hero
academia whoo oh I love it
I'm cool with other people saying yeah
yeah good stuff now next up recon I
think you might want to talk about a
certain enemy highly excited for it but
I'm like it's decent enough um of course
we all know there is a new High School
DxD coming out which I'm so excited for
cannot wait to see the great harem king
he say it's this oh yeah this is this
season highschool DxD here oh yeah it's
been about three to four years at least
since we've seen at the XD series come
on and I'm highly looking forward to it
the most
within this spring 2018 and in second
place for me comes sort out online
alternative gun game that's what I
thought you were gonna say for now it's
not gonna it's not first because it
doesn't
the main cast in it so I'm like nah I
don't I don't know what its gonna have
for us but um that might be new and
exciting for that's the thing that's why
I'm the most excited about it
yeah I have seen those characters though
with new the new sao game called fatal
bullet it is one of the best sao games
ever made gto and those two characters
were actually in there and they're
pretty talkative like mmm I don't know
how in the new sao right so yeah this is
the interesting thing about gun Gale
online being an alternative thing they
could potentially make it quite good
because they have new characters there's
it's like a blank slate and I personally
really liked the GaN BL concept a whole
arc in sort our line I know some people
have mixed feelings like I didn't really
care for Sudan but I did like the whole
concept of death gun and that whole idea
the idea that you know laughing coffin
was now has transferred to this new game
so yeah I think it this this does have
potential but again it's a matter of how
they're going to play it are they gonna
play it safe and do the you know just a
character clone but in a different
setting or are they gonna actually be a
little bit bold with it and potentially
make it something unique I'll give it a
chance I will give it a final Thank You
Mac fine I know Jenny ones the others by
the way because this is a different one
oh yeah yeah I'm genuinely very excited
first I'll give it a chance for you
recon thinking I appreciate it darling I
appreciate it I like it pretty pretty
much just yeah I would just like meter
what what Anna Mac said cuz that's
basically how I feel where it's like it
I'm not a big recon knows this I'm not
like in love with Sao I think Sao has a
lot of really good moments though that
you will not drop it in the first
episode oh no I'm definitely it gets
through it same with the new season like
I like Sao has at least earned like the
three Episode rule from me so ya know
like definitely giving it three this and
whenever the next hour comes out
there is a series that's really pumped
up for and I'm actually going to buy all
of the games and try to play all of them
before it comes out so I can understand
the premise of the anime but persona 5 P
5 I haven't clean it either but I'm
gonna be watching the show persona 5 a
lot of people are excited about it
did they all that they also have some
movies already like anime movies there
was some anime cutscenes I don't know if
they're gonna be including the cutscenes
in the actual anime maybe they will
maybe they won't die I know that there
is like persona 3 films and sort of four
had two in it had two TV anime oh I
didn't know that I gotta check that
stuff out they're not like connectors
yeah yeah I'm not caught up on persona
unfortunately however I know a lot of
people excited a lot of people loved the
games so that's another one that I'll
share so you you don't need to know
anything before going into this one you
do not that I'm aware I think it's like
they give it like the Final Fantasy rule
where it's like you don't have to play
this one to get the next one
like I think it's like a different cast
and you can just dive in I'm just gonna
get the game then just fine and play it
and then watch the anime yeah that works
yeah oh that's amazing
anyone excited for show go get chemo
soma hell yes I am was it is it already
coming like that yeah yeah it's the
continuation of the third season well
people might say it's the fourth season
but it's not really it's exact its next
like a break and then they're yeah yeah
and whatever a few people on the chopper
talk about seven deadly sins season two
that is airing right now in Japan weekly
it started in January so there is no
legal way to watch it in outside of
Japan because Netflix owns it and
they're not simulcasting it but it is
coming out with there's a ceramics and
Google is your friend that's all I'm
gonna say
who is your friend and they want to
smooth is a legal as a respected company
that's all I'm saying I'm able to smooch
other to say speaking of harem we need
more data why ah that's more our boy
recons third season is coming out nobody
heard of it
no I can't believe you guys haven't
known that the third season is coming
out very soon
summer it's coming out summer cool what
about Tokyo ghoul Ria's anyone watching
this oh god okay
uh hey read the manga I caught ice ice
spent an entire two days back-to-back
reading this manga start to finish so
I'm caught up the last two Tokyo ghoul
anime before reading the manga I thought
the first season was okay in the second
season was asked then I read the manga
and found out that the first season is
balls then the second season is double
ass bad and it's by it's the same people
are doing this one and I am very nervous
but for God's sakes like what was he get
to Rea re wherever you want to call it
it's the best part of this of the story
and there's so much cool material for
them to work with they have every
opportunity to make it good will they I
have no idea but I'd rather be
optimistic about it so I'm hoping for
the best but kind of expecting the worst
yeah that is my quote for life that's a
positive surprise yeah exactly yeah
exactly like I I wanted to succeed
because Tokyo ghoul is so good like the
manga is out of this world good to me so
I just I hope that they do it right but
it's Studio clown and they're not that
great for the best
the thing is personally like the girl
talked to in the child say I'm so
excited and freaking out a lot of people
know that while I've been told that the
manga is much better
I couldn't watch
the enemy I'd like dropped it off the
episode six and I was like I'm out
mm-hmm but I have heard that the anime
has done very poorly so not saying that
overall it's a bad story but just like
in terms of the enemy I'm not caught up
I don't intend on getting caught up well
you're not a big horror person are you I
think I remember you telling me that
before like you're not hold big on like
the eating people aspect well no it's
not even that as much as it they're
making it into a sexual fetish yeah like
cannibalism excites them sexually
that's what pisses me off like yo just
this is just like holy [ __ ] it's edgy
tumblr [ __ ] it's that's a part of horror
though that's the whole entire point
like the reason why did we watch it cuz
it turns a 7 but again I don't know how
they do it in the manga so I can't it's
a little different although they can be
much different yes it is a little
different because like yeah in the manga
they could like have like a brief thing
okay I business person gets killed in an
anime to drag it out that it's just like
this grotesque festival stupidity yeah
yeah that's true yeah like I know for
attack on Titan like season 1 reading
the manga after watching season 1 like
the manga was so much more fast paced
that's what they did with one piece as
well I don't mean to bring up one piece
but I'm just saying they did that really
really bad I've noticed I just recently
super jumped into the series and I see
now how bad an episode can be dragged
out yeah for my old school homies out
there though loop on the Third's get
into part five oh my god I am so [ __ ]
excited I am I am I'm so it goddamn
excited I love the bone Conan I love
magic kaito all that stuff that is
microchip well we get along perfect blue
pod I'm so excited
season that's part five yeah ova series
yeah that's a lot yeah yeah I first
discovered move on through or Lupin
however in the proper pronounce
I had a whole debate on this now I
forget which side I was supporting so
Tom Lupo alright but I discovered it
through the film that Miyazaki made the
castle the castle cogliostro and I loved
that film so that's after I was like yo
this is cool [ __ ] yeah looking forward
it's that's a solid movie those they are
they are not those characters like Lupin
is too nice yeah like a cheeky dick yeah
cheeky dick is putting a nice expression
it's funny it's funny though like yeah
[ __ ] but it's funny that's what I
yeah exactly yeah he's how do just loop
on like I can't I can't really explain
him he's kind of he's kind of like if
miguel and tulio from Eldorado or one
guy and smoked and shot people that's
that's who he is by the way have you
seen servant no actually I saw the first
episode it was ok really excited for the
movie that's coming out in eight days
I'll serve him he's so good
however the ending was very rushed but
I'm quite looking forward to the movie
right on I'm looking forward to the boom
go stray dogs movie what happened ninja
Oh Batman ninjas coming out too
it's so sick that dead Apple is coming
out I came everyone's coming up they saw
getting a world rider at least though so
oh it's forever till we see it burn off
a lot of people are talking about attack
on Titan season 3 in the chat and guys
just say no attack on Titan season 3
doesn't come out till July yes here so
that is the Summer 2018 season not the
spring 20 so still three months until
it's a guy thing I am obviously excited
but we still gotta wait fully clean it's
not like last year last year it came out
in April and I don't know why this
stuff around like that it's weird but
it's not like last year it's in July
folder coolies and I think it's in July
and September as well um fully Cooley
the first part of the season three a
second part for September yeah yeah so
full equally also summer it's not yeah
that's a summer one Oh like it's nothing
on spring also uh no talk who says at
occupied season she will be in three
months and four years no don't say so
maybe they just didn't cuz I remember
last last year it was uh like it was
attack on Titan and then immediately
afterwards was my hero and I was like oh
my god Saturday mornings are the freakin
best yes that was crazy
that was awesome yeah I was so
disappointed with her like no it's next
season I was like nothing exactly it's
like what the hell I guess it doesn't
balance oh well
but steins gate zero is another
interesting one now my feelings are
mixed because I really like the original
steins gate series but yeah they had the
whole movie which is kind of like woody
Seuss story like her side of the story
yeah it was like an alternate thing and
I felt it was unnecessary I didn't think
it was nearly as good as the original
series I didn't think it added anything
so I am wondering what this Stein's get
zero is gonna be because it's also
supposed to be like an alternate
timeline so it could potentially be
really disappointing yeah um I I kind of
want to go into it but it it spoils the
original steins gate don't get well the
original is like what 2011 I think we're
good
is that cool yeah as far as I'm
concerned broku three cont do you do you
want me to like wave when I'm done now
that you can yes alright go ahead
are you sure he hasn't watched Lionsgate
I just to be fair I just watched it like
like the beginning of this week oh okay
wash I actually need to wash it because
um the season is over so there's no okay
good I need to get get this time okay
then watch watch the hangouts and when I
wave
I'll have stop talking about spoilers
because I don't want you to know you
know what I think I'm just gonna mute
you okay okay yeah go for it go for it
go for it okay wave wave when you're
done wave him I think I don't care about
artistry no I'll just I'll just mute the
stream so I don't hear anything but just
wait here I'll wait when I'm done for
sure okay okay so signs get zero um do
you remember at the end of steins gate
when he gets the phone call or not the
phone call but like he gets the video
footage from old man Okabe like in the
future in that future that didn't sue so
yeah like he doesn't save her right
yes it's but he he had all that time to
think about a way he could and so that
timeline from what I gather this this
oka Bay is that one it's it's in the
timeline where he doesn't save her yeah
I think the end of got it together from
the description too but then again yeah
question is why apparently like there
was the visually cuz this is based off
the visual novel that came out and
people apparently just went apeshit over
the visual novel they said it was
amazing it was really good so I think
it's writing off the high of that and um
honestly like for me it's funny cuz I
again like I there hasn't been that
break in time between the original
steins gate for me like I just saw a
little while ago so it's I I kind of
like I said I'm in that position where I
want more but it's such a good and it's
kind of like the the Geass thing we're
like yeah I'd love more code geass but
at the same time it was such a good
ending why toy with it but apparently
the visual novel that that's preceded it
is super solid everybody likes it and
this doesn't really like part of my
french but doesn't really [ __ ] with the
ending because it's a it's at the okapi
from the future who we'd know basically
nothing about yeah he's kind of like
stuck in his own future so now we're
learning more
what happened there exactly um but yeah
so that's pretty much I'm looking
forward to it um but I think I'm done
add the one word uh hmm the friend like
that I'm the girl the friend who dresses
like a girl actually becomes a girl yet
well this timeline this timeline no like
this time in this timeline it's just
Chris is dead crew crew Cetina is dead
and he spent like and he's depressed
about it and he's spending like all his
time trying to figure out how to save
her and like the whole pitch is like he
like a an old acquaintance of hers it's
like coming back and she has a way to
like bring back human memories from
deceased people and it's gonna like
screw with him
we'll see you all giving up chance like
I said I I'm afraid they might screw it
up but I will give it a chance
Saint yeah same here should I wave now
yeah yeah yeah okay
I'm gonna talk who keeps wanting $2
because he makes money on cryptocurrency
oh he says that he hasn't gotten around
to watching steins gate yet I definite I
don't know if I can recommend this
season but I'm definitely going to
recommend the next one alright I'm
looking forward to this anime she
Anthony's yelling what I hope I
pronounced it correctly it's a series
where there are there's um like a
scientist couple and he like decides to
put and make all his family test
subjects and give them a bunch of
chemicals and they turn into monsters
yeah yeah they find a medicine to turn
them back into humans it looks like it's
gonna be a very fun series to watch very
in like like comedy series um well that
sounds like my cup of tea it's supposed
to be super cute it was supposed to come
out a while ago too like yeah like I
remember this coming out like or being
previewed like either winter or fall of
last year so like that's in like I
remember seeing like this this show
specifically but it never came out
exciting I would love something like
that it's it seems like it'd be super
cute yeah like I'm totally into it
[Music]
legend of the Galactic Heroes remake I
personally like the original which is
from the 80s like it's slow-paced but I
like military strategies so to me it's
really good but a lot of people would be
like yo man this is boring so I'm
wondering I'm wondering if how they're
gonna do it this remake thing however I
guarantee it that people gonna hate on
it no matter what because it's like if
they try to be to like the original
they're like yo man why is this so
slow-paced you know why is the you know
why they're spending so much time on
politics like an attack on Titan and
want them to mine carsick there's too
much politics here and I'm like as a fan
of politics or someone who knows that
politics is so important like oh god and
then some people will either say that or
the hardcore fans are like yo bro this
is just action now you know what
happened to the intricacies of the
characters so on so I feel like this is
gonna be doomed unless it's like so good
that people are just like no it's it's
in such a predicament like I haven't
seen like the legend every time I say
the legend though I want to say like the
legend 27 but like I'm willing like I
want to watch part of me wants to watch
that first but it's so long that I'm
like I'm I don't know if I'm ever gonna
get around to it yeah it's like what
even more yeah I think it's it's up
there for sure man if I can knock out
700 episodes and six months you can do
it oh no you don't notice that i
procrastinate like a son of a [ __ ]
no yeah I was forced by a friend though
like I I'm definitely gonna check out
the first episode mostly because I have
to check out the first episode of
everything and talk about it online for
them views but the other industry in
which an anime that I'm excited for but
I'm too scared to pronounce it because
I'm gonna chop and screw that so bad
I can try what yeah
good words look like first what does the
cover look like um the cover has like a
demon guy on the front yes black hair
were two small white horns on the side
is like a white fox guy and on the other
side as a girl with brown hair and then
there's three people in the background
with the dojo in the background oh oh I
just saw or was it Oh
Kaku do nor yellow Missy
yeah I agree this is yeah I remember
seeing this I think this is gonna be fun
there's a lot of good stuff there's also
condom bill divers whatever that is
there is no info yet romance between a
double and a human yeah that seems so
cute what like that's what it looks like
you know what I mean
she refuses to marry and works instead
yeah that's cute that is quite so good
there's quite a few shows that are
geared towards your manga fewer you're
sort of like harem cutesy type audience
I'm seeing one here called last period
but it is not about menopause by
j.c.staff it is about magic users it
looks like a harem I'll probably watch
it yeah you boy harem are you gonna
watch the horse girls one one horse girl
no I'm trying to find it it's not like
actual horse girls but yeah where the
hell okay it is an anime that came out a
little while back well that was an
actual horse girl there wasn't it yeah
no yeah that's the one that one's called
try to get me to watch and after three
episodes I was like I I so apologize for
that but know what I'm talking about is
uma Musa may pretty Derby and it's wears
like regular girls run on a track like
horses but there's like guys on their
backs
I know what you're talking about exactly
I seen a trailer for that on Facebook oh
my god they put them in the horse a tire
and everything mm-hmm it's it's real
weird
there's also Giggy Giggy no kitaro which
is the show let's take a super spot and
I'm not salty at all I believe that's a
remake and you don't have to watch the
others yeah like it's supposed to be
like it's a it's an old toy by show but
apparently they're like now you can jump
in here it's just like we're bringing it
back so it's like cool like in like I
joke about like cuz it took supers time
slot right so part of me is just like
but at the same time like I I totally
like it looks fun it's like a spooky
sort of shown in things so I'm totally
on board which I know a lot of people
are fans of I'm really excited for that
like I think it'd be cool there's quite
a few sports series coming out yeah yeah
there's also major the second is that
second season that's a baseball one
right yeah is that is that uh I'm not
sure if that's the second season I think
from what I hear I think you're you you
can jump into it but I don't know for
sure I hope I can jump into it yeah I'm
not a big baseball guy but usually like
I'll kind of give any weight but uh
they're a little bit older yeah I'd say
you're good I don't know also I know no
talk we do not donate money to poke fun
at kill a kill ok no kill Achilles is
brilliant perfection
shutting the [ __ ] down oh yeah another
thing there's piano no Maury so for
piano fans
it's my Gainax yeah I was about to
mention that like I look like something
that would be good with like young
you're lying April like if you like
something like that kind of looks yeah
from your from your friends who brought
you Neon Genesis Evangelion and Gurren
Lagann and totally cool he comes you
know in the woods it'd be great if it
was the translation for the piano man
the piano Matt see
so I just oh my god it's what does the
piano become a mecca because if it
doesn't I'll be pretty pissed
oh it would be so intense any needs they
have a girl with him unable to run it oh
yeah it must a must she plays a violin
in the front oh by the way there's a lot
of interesting ones like the premises
look interesting but this is the problem
with anime is a lot of them have great
premises sword art online but then the
execution is not so good so I see one if
you're called Caligula oh yeah
basically says that people who are
unhappy in the real world are forced
like they've drawn into in our virtual
world where they become students again
and are kind of forced to leave really
like high school over and over again
which is like the type of show that
you're only gonna get a man man oh yeah
I find virtual reality really
interesting and apparently this has AI
and then as well that could be done
really well but let's face it it's more
likely gonna be just harem high school
trash but I would love it not to be yeah
I called mega low box which is about
like underground cyber or boxing like
that looks good too I am sweet it's like
a it's rocky meets Terminator couple of
bebop vibes that's what I am Joe that's
Mike haircut that he's got going on the
Speidel yeah there's one bet recon below
3d kanojo real girl yeah I see oh yeah
gaku and he mostly avoid social life he
curry has only one friend at school who
is also a social misfit and he is marked
brutally by most of his classmates for
being creepy and weird
one day he ends up having to clean the
school pool with Igarashi Erica who
appears to be pretty much everything he
hates and realized girls she skip school
has blunt man oh that's horrible skip
school
anyway the point is has a blunt man oh
this girl might become his first 3d
girlfriend so yeah this is like recon
the the story actually the most
anticipated romance for me that's coming
out is a Paco Nina COI hua musu kashi
that one my don't know if I pronounced
it correctly but it's about a girl who
was a business woman with her working
alongside is her you know as a friend
but secretly an otaku gamer so this is
gonna be interesting
oh my god I read this manga I'm actually
really stell me it's good because I'm so
good it's really good
okay cute I when I read the synopsis I'm
like this is all I want this is like a
hottie too like he's a badass hottie and
he like smoke cigarettes and he's like
you know oh
mysterious hottie like well I just I
like that it's like these two
businesspeople right there you know like
they're supposed to be like all like
straight-laced and Papa blah but the
guy's a gaming otaku and the girls of
fujoshi oh my god that's all I've ever
wanted
it's all I don't know if I would if that
would work out and realize oh I I'm
dated to Joshi they're very very sweet
okay that's my most anticipated rising
generalize and generalize it yeah
boasters we asked for 3d Cano so I'll
give it a go oh man I feel like I'm s
like like but anyway Sheen I sounds like
an interesting thing you like but just
from looking divisional gives me very uh
no hana vibes and then the boy who meets
a girl called Teresa Wagner from
Luxembourg so again some interracial
love I can't wait for that glorious
English yeah
please English please if anything in
terror in resonance some of the English
was too good I was like why it was
really good terror and residents due to
mr. business okay I will just say that
recently okay I never seen the devil man
crybaby series and I watched the first
two episodes last night and there was
like a part where they cut in and the
guy starts speaking English and I'm like
holy [ __ ] he is a very amazing English
accent like he's like amazing lamb like
that is a really good [ __ ] voice
actor I think the say you was like he
was he's Japanese maybe was born a man
in America
yeah like somewhere like in America or
somewhere yes she was born in Japan from
what I guess because I always seen the
first two but he was born in Japan then
he went to school and did all this
science stuff in America yeah it's cool
yeah it's that bad it's I'm really
impressed so far yeah don't get me wrong
like the animation is pretty scrappy at
some points but there's a reason why
it's scrappy though and I like it
yeah it's definitely it's supposed to I
have a video where I go into that it's
though it's good it's it's ya know I
loved of my cry-baby
it was quite the thing like I could talk
about it for hours just about the
philosophy but yes it was quite I
wouldn't recommend it to everyone though
because if they're squeamish you're
gonna like I recommend watching honestly
because I watched the old one first a
long time ago and then I watched double
lady and then I seen this series so it
was totally like amazing nostalgia to me
yeah you need to chillax with the
Satanism
I'm not double back I just like horror I
like I like demons and anime and I will
for I just I'm a big [ __ ] now I gotta
you might like devil's line I'm hyped
for that [ __ ]
that would be Twilight but animu yeah it
looks like just I don't know it could be
good
but probably will that's that's that's
what I get for me again
cool premise but I don't know how it's
gonna be is this thing called Xian pin
Jia Tang which sounds Chinese I don't
know but it says the series centers on a
family where both parents are mad
scientist's so I did already talked
about that animatic yeah we have already
talked about it you did yeah that was
though who are they the families yeah
we're done character turns his family
into monsters and he has to find a
medicine to turn them back into humans I
I completely spaced it's so cool premise
whether it's gonna be good I don't know
but like I would like it I hope it's
good
what are you spacing out on you're the
host of this show well how can you be
all right I didn't even realize um to
Raikou the animation that's a based off
a really really good manga like really
good that is it gonna be an amazing
horror if you guys are in a horror
that's going to be good yeah yeah for me
is devil's line probably I probably not
right cool man that that was really
really good
that's all torte it's basically torture
porn my favorite I'll shout out Butler's
if only because it appeals to my food on
she said it's yeah pretty much a sister
complex one yeah Ellis or Alice and
torture porn in the same one because
that'll be great feeling me
let's compare compare like combined
fetishes and see what happens
lolly is in line with fires with no
vampire demons then you need like you
need like lollies tentacles and horror
alright so yeah know how we always like
water one hentai series every season
we're having another warm
we're another hentai series we're go TV
shorts it's called a my shoe BOTS ooh
like we've been getting these for quite
a while
do you like shorts hentai goes like five
minutes right yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't care for that it's like if I'm
gonna watch hentai I'm gonna watch
straight hentai brah
oh man I like watching like I'm gonna go
like pathway you got to go the full
friggin Monty yeah I mean it looks good
as a police officer with a alright
technically the Code Geass third movie
is considered part of the range season
so that's May 26th I'm hoping that we
get some actual news about season three
at the end of this movie if not I'm
gonna be pissed as a lot because we're
gonna lose for a year and a half and
it's annoying it's pretty I think that's
we've covered all the major ones I mean
I know someone's gonna be like in the
comment Jon bro we didn't talk about
this random one [ __ ] you that's the best
one but like there's so many there's
literally so many anime coming out not
to mention movies not to mention shorts
and oh yeas it's crazy so yeah I don't
know is there anything like we really
need to discuss um like one day you're
like no I have to talk about comic girls
or whatever I'm trying to think I
there's two I know that we haven't
touched on that I was like oh I just
want to tag that one Oh Coco chiku you
boy no happy cos that okay that I'm so
torn on because that show was really
good like that's that shows really good
this is a whole new cast even though the
last one had a definitive ending so you
can so you are actually gonna enjoy
watching guys in their abs joy yeah dude
I like free man or like have we met
remember I'm the free guy I have the
free figures they're sitting I'm looking
at them like I can see them I have it
Schwimmer guys yeah um but yet like know
that that show was well if you're for
joshi that's a good show you have to
specifically it is for Joshi Bay to the
extreme but if you're a guy it's called
pedantry but anyway move
the two shows I wanted I want to tag at
the end of this there's the new North
Star
show know that we don't know we have no
like if I came ever there's a synopsis
somewhere but it's basically it's Fist
of the North Star but like the original
can shoot oh so it's ten shadows great
uncle and it takes place in like World
War two ish I think so it's like another
prequel thing it's a prequel thing so
it's not set in the wasteland sounds
like okay I'm kind of disappointed but
like it's still you know it's still
North Star so it'll be fun and then it
apparently it's 3d models so I'm like
yeah yeah but the other one I want to
mention just cuz it sounds so off the
wall is a bone show it's called and so
of course it's like my [ __ ] but it's he
sown tommaso Tong and it's about girls
who pilot mechs with the mechs are
actually dragons like actual real
dragons that they put metal [ __ ] on top
of so that sounds cool
I see I actually it's true like it's
true that in animes like they have some
cool purposes for example unknown otaku
just combine a whole bunch of fetishes
in a message I appreciate the donation
man but I'm not reading that you know I
mean how much cutie honey - I totally
forgot about cutie honey someone in the
chat remind me cutie honey's coming back
that's you know that's only because
devil man crybaby came out I was like
that's the old like it gonna this is
gonna be the year of gonna guy yes yeah
that's gonna be good - I didn't I went
past it three times Jesus yeah I did the
same thing I was like oh yeah like
everything's going to be a very
interesting season we have some really
big popular anime coming some really big
spin-offs and equals it's gonna be
pretty crazy I'm looking forward to it
like I said
as usual we could get a lot of
disappointment
people not you know what bring it on
let's do it oh yeah do it
there there is this series called fumika
DG con in the TV shorts I have no idea
I've never seen this premise before it's
about two characters in the whole series
and every time there's it's gonna
showcase them waiting on a railroad
telling stories that's yeah that could
be colors story tie panamania I have no
idea maybe they're just gonna show the
same scene over and over and over again
of them waiting on a railroad but with
new stories to tell I have no idea
that's gonna be good that's what's
interesting they should just keep like
rearing the endless eight from Harvey I
was just much says that they just like
what knows this is a social experiment
but okay I think that's it for today we
got to get out of here I think that's it
some plans not together because we're
communities but we still have plans
thank you for joining us everyone in to
chat thank you guys here tell us before
we go who you are and what you do
starting with anime recon okay what is
up its your boy recon and I do known as
the harem king and the person who has
the shittiest taste and all of anime
thank you very much guys um I do top
tens so yeah if you want any awesome
recommendations come to my channel if
you're running out of anime I'm the guy
you need to see but remember I have the
shittiest taste thank you know what she
means you like you like the harem you
like the oppai you like that [ __ ] you
like the teasing but no actual sex yeah
that's where to go yeah exactly that's
where to go the blue ball King anime
read okay Jojo do you okay
uh hello I am Jojo talks too much I have
a show that I think it's probably the
thing that I'm most known for called in
a minute where I cover seasonal anime
reviews all in under one minutes just
waiting for the spring season to start
so that I can cover a bunch of [ __ ] it's
gonna be super hype and I also do
random series reviews on anime then
they're totally unstructured but they're
fun and you should check them out
by all means check out Jojo link in the
description he's also known for making a
lot of sense on Twitter and some people
can't handle it
ya know I gotta follow you right away
yeah check them out and now I got it to
you
Ohio's where I'm from yeah yeah that's
what we do over here almost markiplier
and Jay Paul what up umm I am now I
gotta I do Anime News we switched it to
monthly because I'm a full time artist
and in a few months we'll go back to
weekly or twice a week again but that's
what I do okay some of your art since
you're full-time artists on YouTube
we're waiting for her I know wait wait
nice post on Twitter and Instagram
well actually I less slack on it it's
all on Twitter I always post everything
on Twitter you know twitter twitter is
just a mess right now but and have fun
whatever sometimes you gotta just turn
it off always if you want to keep the
chat going you can join us into this
court and I member discord a link in the
description there's a lot of people
there who like to chat and argue and
yeah thanks for joining us and until
next time see ya space cowboys hey